[Music]
sports
are basically the only way to reach a
massive audience
on live television yes uh it used to be
the tv show dallas or hill street blues
or what they could all reach
pretty substantial audiences because of
dvrs and just
people watch tv when they want they fast
forward through commercials but the only
way for advertisers
to reach a large amount of viewers and
have them captured is through live
sports and so once that became the
reality
sports became more of a target of the
left in terms of if you want to reach a
large segment of americans and move them
politically or any whatever message you
want to get out
it really has to be done through sports
you have to have an alliance with the
nfl the nba major league baseball
and so sports became a target and people
on the left
realized that sports had been
a pretty conservative
endeavor
messaging the values in sports align
with conservatism
sports
tied to religion
coaches pray before and after the games
lead the team and i think the left
figured out that
no we have to move and change sports if
we're going to get our message out in a
big way and so you know
it started before this but i i said
early on in 2016 when kaepernick started
kneeling like he's the trojan horse
he's he's going to empower the left to
basically take over the sports world and
they've done that he changed the entire
discussion around sports by kneeling
and
creating the opportunity
for the sports media to come in behind
him
and support what he's doing and make it
this really polarizing issue if you
don't support kaepernick you're a racist
and and next thing you know
roger goodell and the nfl they start to
fold they don't want to be criticized
by the left by the new york times
by
social media
and so they started incorporating all
the black lives matters sloganeering and
messaging
into their
endeavors and so now when you look at
the nba or the nfl
the commercial breaks
the slogans on the back of helmets and
on the field
it's all the blm marxist stuff bake
right all the leftist stuff bake right
into the games
and they're using sports
to
move people politically
uh
and and to redefine
american patriotism and and so sports
used to be this great celebration of the
best values of americana and now they've
turned it into a platform for
the very wealthy athletes
to wag their finger at america and say
you know you've screwed over black
people and people of color you've
screwed over the gay community you've
screwed over everybody
it's been pretty brilliant the way
sports have been manipulated
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else